[Music]
a sign of how scared people in haiti are
a false rumor spread on social media
that the u.s was giving out visas
a massive crowd showed up at the embassy
only to be disappointed
faced with this reality the haitian
people are left to themselves
they cannot go out they want to go to
safe places
when people heard the rumors saying that
the u.s embassy is giving exile to the
people
they came haitian officials have asked
the u.s for more than
that a contingent of u.s troops to help
secure the country
without asking for the occupation of the
country
we are asking for small troops to assist
and help us u.s media reports the troops
will not be deployed
instead they will send law enforcement
to help with the investigation
into the assassination of jovanelle
moise his widow
also injured in the shooting sent this
message on social media
you knew who the president was fighting
against these people hired mercenaries
to kill the president and his family due
to the projects for roads
electricity drinking water supply
organization of the referendum and
elections
for the final abolition of political
transitions the president has always
believed in institutions and stability
it's not clear who paid for the
mercenaries who allegedly carried out
the attack
many of them former members of the
colombian military but while that
investigation continues
so does the political uncertainty
the interim prime minister claude joseph
says he's in charge
but he was set to be replaced before the
killing by ariel henry
who now along with politician joseph
lambert says
they will take over lambert tweeted that
his saturday inauguration
was postponed there is a behind the
scenes push in the country
and in washington to figure out the way
forward but so far there
is no clear solution for a
poverty-ravaged country
battered by gang violence the
coronavirus and now
political infighting patty culhane al
jazeera
washington